quand le ciel était encore noire
le monde était entouré de murs qui
grimpaient jusqu'aux cieux ce monde
était du matin au soir enveloppée de
fumée
ce monde ne savait pas ce qu'il y avait
au delà ce monde n'avait jamais vu un
ciel étoilé mon papa l'appelait la ville
cheminée tout simplement parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de chemini
[Musique]
c'est parti
pendant ces jours de repos tu vas pas
aller dans les rues parler aux gens d'un
monde sans cheminée
la dernière nuit de la ville de la nuit
le spectacle au tpi dans valse que bruno
va commencer
l'histoire d'un homme de lumière caché
derrière la fumée
mais les gens traités papa de menteur et
il disait les étoiles ça n'existe pas
personne ne l'écoutait
jusqu'au jour où celle du la rencontrer
et l'homme une poubelle
voici l'histoire de la dernière nuit de
la vie de la nuit
[Musique]
ne restent pas de regarder en l'air
reparti et tu vas tomber
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
il était une fois une ville enveloppée
de fumée où il était interdit de lever
les yeux au ciel
[Musique]
un petit ramoneur fait la connaissance
de poubelles
[Musique]
les excuses et les étoiles les étoiles
un secret bien gardé transmis de père en
fils ici te regarde bien la route tu
verras qu'il y a quelqu'un d'écouté
dis-moi l'aube ichi c'est quoi un ami
[Musique]
donc tu sais déjà que le monde extérieur
existe
j'espère 3d
[Musique]
pour m'aider tout ce que papa voulait me
faire savoir on doit le dire à tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
elle faisait la manche
croix aux trois réussis tu es le seul
[Musique]